other things I pray that you listen
closely and carefully because what
you're going to hear May save your life
or the life of your loved one Dr Wallock
in 1991 was nominated for the Nobel
Prize he's had many many fabulous things
in his
life there's no way I can tell you how
pleased I am to have him here in Kansas
City tonight and I want to turn the time
over now to Dr Joel wallik would you all
give him a big
[Applause]
hand
how many of you grew up on a farm or
still work a farm or have anything to do
with livestock I'll tell you what you're
my kind of people because I grew up on a
farm in West St Louis County back in the
50s and uh we started out with beef
Cales and uh if if you raise livestock
the only way you can make money is if
you raise a lot of your own feed for
those of you don't have that experience
and so we raised our own corn
and we raised our own soybeans and our
own hay and we had a truck come out from
the mill and this truck would come out
from the mill and it would grind up the
corn and the soybeans and the hay and
then we would add sacks of vitamins
minerals trace minerals and we'd make
pellets out of it and this is what we
would feed the calves in 6 months time
we'd ship them to Market to be
slaughtered or we'd save back some of
the best ones for oursel we'd knock them
in the head and eat them put it
bluntly and um it always fascinated me
as a teenager that we did that for those
cats six months ship them off to be
slaughtered or weed eat them and we
wanted to live to be hundred years of
age without any aches and pains and
guess what we didn't take any vitamins
or minerals and that bothered me so I
asked my dad I'd say hey Pops how come
you do that for those Cals you don't do
that for us and he'd give me this good
old Missouri farm wisdom he'd say things
like shut up boy you're getting this
farm fresh food and we hope you
appreciate it and of course I was very
quiet then because I didn't want to miss
out on any meals well then when I went
to school I went to the University of
Missouri the um School of Agriculture
and I got my degree in agriculture and
it was very interesting to me that uh I
got my major in animal husbandry and
nutrition my minor was in field crops
and soils then I got into veterinary
school as a freshman Veterinary student
I learned the answer to my question and
the answer is this we know how to
prevent and cure diseases in animals
with nutrition and the reason why we do
that is because we don't have major
medical we don't have hospitalization
Blue Cross Blue Shield we don't have um
Medicare we don't have Hillary to watch
out for
us if you're going to make money as a
farmer you better know how to do stuff
yourself and you better uh do it
efficiently with feed and nutrition if
you can well to make a long story short
after I got out of a veter school I went
to Africa for two years and I was able
to fulfill a Boyhood dream I was able to
be a Frank Buck for two years and work
with Marlon Perkins many of you will
remember him from the Mutual of Omaha's
Wild Kingdom and he's a great gentleman
and after two years of working with
elephants and rhino people used to ask
me are you a small animal vet or a large
animal vet well I was tell them I'm a
extra large animal vet because I worked
with elephants and rhinos well after two
years he sent me a telegram and said
would you come back to the St Louis Zoo
and work with us we need a Wildlife
veterinarian at the zoo for a special
project we're given a $7.5 million Grant
from the um National Institutes of
Health and what we need is a
veterinarian who will do autopsies of
animals that die of natural causes in
the zoo oh I was just Overjoyed to do
that and so I came back and and did that
and of course I not only did autopsies
for animals that died in the St Louis
Zoo but the Brookfield Zoo in Chicago
the Bron zoo in New York the National
Zoo the LA Zoo and so forth and my job
again was to do autopsies of animals
that died of natural causes in the zoo
and look for a species of animals that
was Ultra sensitive to pollution this is
because during the early 60s we had just
learned about pollution and ecological
problems and disasters and nobody quite
knew what to do and so I was supposed to
find a species of animals that was extra
sensitive to this and use them much like
we did the canaries in the mine you know
the old Welsh coal miners used to put a
canary in a little wicker cage and take
it down in the mine and if methane gas
or carbon monoxide would leak into the
mine the canary would drop off the perch
and die first and the men knew to get
out before the mine blew up or they
suffocated well again to make a long
story short uh over a period of some 12
years I did
17,500 autopsies and over 454 species of
animals and 3,000 human beings who lived
in close proximity to zoos and the thing
that I found out was this every animal
and every human being who dies of
natural causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency and that fascinated me it
went back took me back to those calves I
said Gee that's fascinating everybody's
dying of nutritional deficiencies and we
could document this at autopsy both
chemically and biochemically and so
forth and things you saw with the eye at
the autopsy table well that fascinated
me and I wrote 75 scientific articles I
wrote uh eight multi-author textbooks
and one textbook of my own cost 140
bucks for medical students and I'm sure
the only thing they do is use them for
door
stops and it couldn't get anybody
excited I was on
2020 uh I was on 1700
newspapers I was in magazines I was in
every new network TV that you can think
of and guess what couldn't get anybody
excited back in the 60s about
nutrition so what I did was went back to
school and became a physician to use
everything thing I had learned in
veterinary school about nutrition and my
human
patients and to no surprise to me it
worked I spent 12 years up in Portland
orgon in general practice and um it was
very fascinating what I'm going to share
with you tonight is what I learned over
those 10 12 years using nutrition with
my human patients and if you take home
only 10% if you take home only 10% it
will save you an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery it will save you a
Gob of money and those of you in
Missouri you know what that means a go
means a
lot and will save you and fact it will
add on many healthful years to your life
okay it'll add many helpful years to
your life well you can't do this you
can't get these helpful years and you
can't have longevity you can't live to
your genetic potential just falling off
a stump uh you have to do some things
and the first thing I have to do is
convince you that it is worth doing
these things I'm going to start out by
convincing you that the genetic
potential for human beings is 120 to 140
years or genetic potential for longevity
okay 120 to 140 years there's no less
than five cultures whose people live to
be 120 to 140 starts out in the Tibetans
in western China uh these people were
popularized back in
1934 um by James Hilton he wrote a book
called The Lost Horizon many of you will
remember reading that as a puler
prizewinning book way back then and they
did a movie of that in 1937 it's a very
long movie about 3 hours you can get it
from any Blockbuster Video and I would
encourage you to get it and look at it
when you have three hours it's a great
movie and the oldest living person that
has some documentation I'm sure there's
a certain amount of exaggeration in
there but there is some documentation
was a fellow a Dr Lee Li uh from China
along this Tibetan border and this
fellow when he was 150 years old
quote unquote received a um big
certificate from the Imperial Chinese
government uh he was born in
1677 150 years later he was given a
certificate by the Imperial Chinese
government for being 150 years and then
when he got to be 200 years they sent
him another 50 years later they sent him
another certificate and supposedly he
died at age
256 and as people of that nature he was
written up in the New York Times in 1933
when he died in the London times and so
this is fairly well documented but he
may have only been 200 years old uh I
don't know if he was 256 but this is the
um person that led James Hilton to write
that story then uh there's in
1967 or 68 there was a remake of that
movie it was a color version if you
haven't seen that was called shangra La
I'd urge you to see that then in eastern
Pakistan
there's a group of people called the
hunzas and these people are very famous
for longevity 120 140 if you've been in
Alternative Health for any length of
time you've heard their name at least
then in what is now Western uh Russia it
used to be the Soviet Union the Russian
Georgians were made famous during the
70s by Dan and yogurt you remember the
old Crimea War U veterans they get their
uniform on they'd hold a saber up and
they would get a cup of Dan and yogurt
and smile a lot and you're supposed to
make the mental leap that it was the Dan
and yogurt that made them live to be
120 then just south of them the
Armenians the abian and the azeris are
famous at least in in the Soviet Union
they were studied for some 60 years
because they routinely Liv to be 120 to
140 in fact in 19 uh 73 the January
issue of the 19 of the um um National
Geographic 1973 January uh National
Geographic did a special article on
people who Liv to be hundred and are
older and they featured these people and
there's a great pictorial article you
know National Geographic is very good
about coming out with pictures and three
of these dozens of pictures that were in
that article I remember one of them was
a lady who was 136 years old she was
sitting in a wicker chair with a big
Cuban cigar in one hand and an 8 o glass
of vodka in the other and she was
partying she was having a good time she
was not in a nursing home all slouched
over and and you know ready to have
somebody take another 20 500 bucks out
of her checking account uh she was
enjoying herself at 136 then there was a
semicircle of couples boy girl boy girl
boy girl and they were celebrating their
100th and 115th and 120th wedding
anniversaries then the third picture
that I remember is a gentleman who is
picking tea leaves up at the timber line
in the Caucasus Mountains in Armenia and
um he was listening to a one of these
little transistor radios back then and
according to his birth records and and
baptismal records his military records
and the birth records of his children uh
the National Geographic said that he was
167 years of age and the oldest living
person at that time in the Western
Hemisphere the vilcabamba Indians in
Ecuador very famous they live in the
Andes and then in Southeastern Peru my
favorites the titty kakas I just like
them because I like the name they're
sort of east of the Machu Picchu uh the
old Community the titty kakas around
Lake tiaka and of course they're very
famous uh for living to be 120 to 140
well in May 11th just about a month ago
the oldest living American at this time
and documented through the Guinness
World Book of Records was Margaret ski
she was from Radford Virginia she died
at age of
115 and she died of a nutritional
deficiency you can tell that from her
her
obituary she died of the complications
of a fall
what did she die from osteoporosis very
good she died of a Calcium deficiency
she had no heart disease no cancer no
diabetes no other infirmities but she
died three weeks after a fall because
she didn't have enough calcium very
interesting also her daughter said that
she had a craving for sweets until she
died and that's a disease called Pica
we'll talk about that in a little bit
but usually when you have a craving for
chocolate if you're a chocaholic or a
sugarholic that means that you have a
deficiency of chromium and vadium and
we'll talk about that in a minute then
in a third world country in Niger in
Africa a chief by the name of Bower at
age 126 was eulogized by one of his
wives so I assume it was plural it had
many wives and she was bragging about
him and his death at age of 126 he was
still in possession of all his own
teeth okay so you assume that other
faculties are working
too then here's a gentleman uh from
Syria at age 133 he died in July of 1993
and he was in the Guinness World Book of
Records not because he was 133 there's
been many people live longer than that
um not because he remarried for the
fourth time at age 80 but because he
fathered nine children after the age of
80 and this meant if you add up nine
months for each child and a year for
breastfeeding for each one and a year
between each one of the children he was
still fathering children after age of
100 and that's what got him into the
Guinness World Book of Records so
there's still hope for you fellas
then those of you who like science um in
November of
1993 those six biospherians came out of
that dome in Arizona they were in there
for two years um three couples and they
were supposed to eat the perfect food
and recycle the atmosphere and grow
their own food and whatnot and have no
pollution in their water or air or food
and when they came out they were
examined by medical gerontologists from
UCLA University offor California Los
Angeles and uh they put all this
information their physical and their
blood work and so forth into the medical
computers at UCLA and the medical
computer said that and projected that
they could live to be 165 years old if
they continued to do what they were
doing so all of that just says to you
that there's a there's a possibility you
can live to be 120 to 140 and when I
grew up on the farm we could grow 200 uh
bushels of corn per acre and with all
the labor and all the fertilizer and
everything else you did
you could make a profit if you grew 200
bushels per acre but if you only got 100
bushels per acre and put out that same
effort and the same fertilizer cost
you'd lose
money and so I want you to think about
it the average lifespan for an American
today is
75.5 the average lifespan for an MD or a
doctor is
58 you want to gain 20 years
statistically just don't go to medical
school you want to live to be 120 to 140
there's only two basic things real
simple two things to remember number one
you have to avoid the pitfalls you have
to not step on the landmines I call it
and those of you in the military you
know what that means um you do something
stupid like step on one of those things
you kill yourself wastefully or
unnecessarily and of course if you play
Russian Roulette or smoke excessively or
drink excessively or wear a black
sweatsuit and run down the middle of the
highway at 2 o'clock in the morning
you're going to get struck by a car uh
all of those things are fool hearty but
it's amazing how many tens of thousands
of people D in America from doing those
stupid things every year the last thing
I will share with you on that subject of
avoiding the
landmines I'd suggest very strongly to
you that you avoid going to doctors and
I'm going to back up that statement
which is a pretty strong statement with
a um statement from Ralph nater's group
in January of
1993 just about a year and a half ago uh
January 13th he put out a news release
based on a three-year study on the
causes of death in American hosital
hospitals and it was 1500 page report
this three-year study and I'm not going
to waste your time or Mine by going over
the whole thing word for word but the
bottom line says a lot the bottom line
says a lot and here it is quote this is
from Ralph nater now he's a consumer
Advocate advocate for those of you who
don't know him who watches out for us
quote 300,000 Americans are killed each
year in hospitals alone as a result of
medical negligence unquote I'm going to
read that figure again because it's a
huge figure quote 300,000 Americans are
killed each year in hospitals alone as a
result of medical negligence unquote now
he didn't say Slipped Away quietly out
of neglect in a Conner somewhere while
they're waiting for an x-ray he used the
word killed when you use the word killed
that means there was a procedure the
doctor was doing went wrong somehow that
means that they gave them a wrong
prescription they put a decimal point in
the wrong spot and gave them an
incorrect dosage these people were
killed
300,000 to appreciate how big a figure
that is you have to compare that with
our military losses in Vietnam over 10
years where we lost 56,000 people over
10 years or an average of only 5,600 a
year on a field of battle where people
had guns and artillery and explosives
trying to kill each
other and millions of people poured out
into the streets and protested that war
we had political Anarchy in the last
three years of the War uh students took
over University ities and colleges with
guns and explosives National Guardsman
shot students at Kent State in Ohio we
chased a president out of the
presidency for 5,600 military personnel
a year and here's one profession that
takes your tax money in the form of
Medicare and Medicaid and kills 300,000
of us a year according to Ralph nater
and I believe him he has no acts to
grind and you can go out in the street
any day of the week in any City and
there isn't even a crazy Street Preacher
out there with a sign that says protect
us from doctors
I want you to think about that folks
that's number one you have to avoid
stepping on the landmine so there's a
certain value in treating yourself when
you can or preventing disease so you
don't have to get treated now the second
thing you have to do number two is you
have to do the positive things you have
to do the positive things and I'm going
to start out here by just putting a
figure up on the board it's the number
90 and you need 90 nutrients in your
diet every day you need 60
minerals
you need 16
vitamins you need 12 essential amino
acids or protein building blocks and you
need three essential fatty acids you
need 90 nutrients in your daily diet
otherwise you're going to get a
deficiency disease if you don't have
them in complete numbers and optimal
amounts well I can tell you that I was
one of those nerds back when I was in
college I had a clipboard we didn't have
computers back then so I had a clipboard
and I I was one of those funny guys with
glasses and would walk up and down in
the Student Union there in Columbia and
say uh do you take vitamins and minerals
I was still fascinated by that and and
of course people kind of look at you
crazy and say well yeah I take vitamin E
and I'd wait for him to come up with the
other 89 and they didn't they just oh I
take vitamin E well today if you ask
people do you take food supplements they
say oh yeah I take
Tums because that's what you know they
hear all the time well again you need 90
nutrients if you're going to make it but
the newspapers know and the magazines
and TV and radio knows that we're
interested in Health and Longevity and
and supplements so they all talk to us
not because the medical profession has
asked them to do that in their stad the
medical profession doesn't say hey we're
so busy saving people with surgery and
chemotherapy and radiation and
pharmaceuticals would you please educate
the people on nutrition they do it
because it sells newspapers well my
favorite article of all time appeared in
Time Magazine April 6th 1992 to and if
you haven't read it I'd urge you to get
it out of a school library or public
library and photocopy it stick one copy
on the door in the bathroom and one on
the refrigerator it's a cover article it
says the real power of vitamins new
research shows they may help fight
cancer heart disease and the ravages of
Aging again there's six positive pages
in here there's only one negative
sentence and was issued by a medical
doctor who is asked by the writer of the
article what do you think what do you
think about vitamins and minerals for
people as food supplements and here's
what the doctor said said quote popping
vitamins doesn't do you any good sniffs
Dr Victor Herbert a professor of
medicine at New York City's Mount siai
medical school we get all the vitamins
we need in our diets and taking
supplements just gives you expensive
urine unquote well to give you a
Missouri translation of that that means
you're just peeing away your dollars if
you take vitamins and minerals you might
as well wad up your dollars and throw
them in the toilet and flush them away
cuz you're not getting any redeeming
value from it those quacks are just
taking your money for those vitamins and
minerals that's what he was trying to
say got published so it must be true
right I'll tell you what after having
done those
17,500 autopsies and 454 species of
animals from around the world and 3,000
humans and liking to be healthy myself
and having children and grandchildren
and not too distant future
great-grandchildren I'd rather pee out
50 cents or a dollar a day worth of
excess vitamins and minerals is pretty
cheap insurance because if you don't
invest in yourself to the tune of a buck
a day for vitamins and minerals guess
what you're going to invest in the
lifestyle of an MD somewhere because
when you pay the medical doctor your fee
for going to see him not one penny of
that goes to study how to diagnose or
treat or prevent a catastrophic disease
in a little child like who was in here
earlier or how to prevent or diagnose or
treat better breast cancer or prostate
cancer and
adults guess what the that money goes
for pays the doctor's mortgage makes his
Mercedes payment it pays a tuition for
his kids to go to medical school at hav
it you know have it is up in
Baston pays a tuition for his kids to go
to law school at Yale I believe because
we've made doctors
wealthy between 1776 and the second
world war the US government spent $80
million on Healthcare and Health Care
research and studies right now we're at
1 Point 2 trillion doar a year for
health care and it's free we all know
it's free
right I like that lady she says like
heck it's not free but we're supposed to
believe it's free and everybody wants
more of it and more free stuff well I'll
tell you what if we used a human type
medical system for the agricultural
industry and the livestock your
hamburger cost $275 a pound on the other
hand if you use the agricultural health
system that we use in animals for humans
your monthly insurance premiums for a
family of five would be $10 a month you
take your choice well I believe since
we've made them wealthy through
Insurance programs and government
subsidies I believe they owe us
something and I believe they owe us at
least as much as the uh Industries do
according to for instance recall notices
this was started of course I don't know
25 years ago when Ralph nater learned
that the Ford Motor Company had made a
Pinto car with a rear- end gas tank that
would blow up when you got hit from
behind at 20 mph fry everybody in the
car and when people complained to Ford
Motor Company they said well you're just
dumb for getting in a car accident we're
not going to pay you for that Ralph
nater says no it's a faulty design so he
went to a federal court and the judge
agreed with him and through a court
order forced Ford Motor Company to send
everybody a uh recall notice with a
registered letter bring that car in and
they'll fix it for nothing but they kill
three 300,000 a year and nobody protests
as long as we get ours free and that
scares me that attitude at any rate I've
got a bunch of these recall notices you
should have gotten over the last couple
years we'll go through them quickly
number one is ulcers how many of you
ever heard that ulcers is caused by
stress okay everybody's heard that if
you don't raise your hand you got
Alzheimer's or your fibon
right well we knew 50 years ago and in
the veterinary industry that uh ulcers
at least in pigs was caused by a
bacteria called helicobactor pylori and
of course we couldn't get one of these
high- priced stomach surgeons from Mayo
Clinic in fact we always used to yell
hold the Mayo when they say stuff like
that and um otherwise your pork chops
would be $275 a pound to pay for that
kind of surgery and we learned that with
a trace mineral called bismuth and the
tetracycline antibiotic that we could
prevent and and cure those stomach
ulcers and pigs without surgery so
that's what we did cost five bucks to
cure a pig of stomach ulcers with the
Bismuth the trace mineral Tetra cycling
well the National Institutes of Health
now not the national Inquirer but the
National Institutes of Health came out
in February of this year February 1994
and said ulcers are caused by a bacteria
called helicobactor pylori not stress
and they can be cured they actually use
the Cure word in this news release
medical researchers never do that they
always say it shows promising results or
maybe beneficial they use the Cure word
National Institutes of Health and they
say can be cured with a combination of
the trace mineral bouth and Tetra
cycling well for those of you who don't
know what bismo comes in you can get it
from any grocery store or drugstore it's
pink about 295 for an 8 O bottle and
it's called Pepto Bismol so a teaspoon a
day full of Pepto Bismol and some rmis
and calf scour pellets you can take care
of
ulcers now you have your choice whether
you're going to treat your own for five
bucks or go get Whitted on that's your
choice then what's the number two cause
of death Americans terrible disease
called cancer right now when doctors get
information on cancer you'd think they'd
photocopy that and when they send you
that bill they should send you some
photocopies of this stuff well in
September of
1993 the um National Cancer Institute
not the national Inquirer but the
National Cancer Institute and the um
havid Medical School up in Baston did a
study on cancer patients and they came
out and they said an anti-cancer diet
was found well at any rate they picked
China to do this study because in one
Province henan Province in China they
have the highest rate of cancer in the
whole world they took 29,000 people for
five years in this study and what they
did was give them different vitamins and
minerals at Double the recommended daily
allowance for Americans now that's a
trivial amount for instance they use
vitamin C for one group and of course
the um RDA recommended daily allowance
for vitamin C is 60 milligrams double
thats can be 120 milligrams you can't go
into a health food store and find a
vitamin C tablet or capsule for less
than 500 milligrams for an adult and of
course lonis Pauling the gentleman with
two Nobel prizes says if you want to
prevent and treat cancer with vitamin C
you got to use 10,000 milligrams a day
well all the doctors who used to argue
with him back 35 years ago were all dead
and today lonus Pauling still 94 and he
works 14 hours a day seven days a week
on his Ranch in the Big Sir in
California and teaches at the University
of California San Francisco so you have
to make up your choice whether you're
going to listen to the dead doctor or
Linus
paing your
choice okay vitamin C double the RDA
nothing happened vitamin A Double the
RDA nothing happened zinc riboflavin the
trace mineral malib inum n nothing
happened in one group they got a major
benefit in this group they got three
nutrients at one time they got vitamin E
they got beta carotene and the trace
mineral selenium that those three were
at Double the RDA and if you get a half
a percent benefit in any nutritional or
pharmaceutical experiment you've made a
major major Improvement in Humanity's
life and so these articles get published
so I want you to remember that statistic
a half a percent is major benefit well
in this group that received the vitamin
E beta keratin and selenium for 5 years
deaths from all causes were reduced by
9% almost 10 out of every hundred or one
out of every 10 who were going to die in
that 5 Years From Any cause
survived then cancers all cancers 133%
survived who would have died without
those three nutrients
so 13 out of 100 lived who would have
died and then the type of cancer that
was most prevalent in henan Province
stomach and esophageal cancer 21% lived
who would have died 21 out of a 100
lived now to me those are significant
numbers and your physician for the
number two cause of death in America
should have sent every one of you a
photocopy of that at least giving you
information even if he didn't want to
give you the advice give you the
information let you make up your own
mind well here's one I think is funny on
one hand and on the other side it tells
you the attitude of Physicians this has
to do with arthritis it was in um
September 24th 1993 that it was released
again it was from the havit medical
school and the Baston VA Hospital how
many of you in here have ever been to a
VA Hospital anybody in this room okay
good well you know the people who've
been to a VA Hospital you have two
opportunities to give your life for your
country one's on the field of battle and
the others in the VA Hospital
right well any the title of the release
was chicken protein hals to swelling and
pain of arthritis in a patient trial and
what they did they took people who
failed to respond in any way to medical
treatment for arthritis these people got
gold shots mesot trexate they got
aspirin prazone cortisone everything
else you can think of physical therapy
and the only thing left for them was
joint replacement surgery okay now
before Harvard Medical School and the VA
hospital was going to give it to them
they said look we're looking for some
people who are willing to suffer for for
90 more days just 3 months because we
want to try something a short-term
experiment and they got 29 volunteers
and what they did for those 29
volunteers who failed to respond in any
way to medical treatment for arthritis
was they gave them a heaping teaspoonful
of groundup dried chicken cartilage in
their orange juice every morning just a
heaping teaspoon of ground up chicken
cartilage and in 10 days according to
Harvard Medical School all the pain and
inflammation was gone these are people
who didn't respond in any way to medical
treatment in 30 days they could open up
a new pickle jar that had never been
opened and 90 days 3 months they had
maximum return of
function now here's the funny part the
funny part comes by a statement of the
guy who was the director of that study
from Harvard Medical School and here's
what he said quote listen to the words
are very important quote after three
months it was clear that the drug was
beneficial unquote because it worked
chicken cartilage had become a
drug
you can see he's thinking about patent
numbers and his eyes are rolling around
with 300 bucks a capsule 20 patients and
you can just see him calculating
right that means if you go to Kentucky
Fried Chicken and you buy a bucket of
chicken throw away the skin and the meat
and eat the ends off the bones you're
practicing medicine without a
license and if you go to a Kentucky
Fried Chicken in the middle of the night
in the dark of the night and you go to
their dumpster and you root through
there and you collect two five gallon
feed buckets full of chicken bones and
you take them home with a hammer and you
pound off the ends of those bones and
dry your own cartilage in the microwave
you know you're manufacturing a um
pharmaceutical and the FDA is going to
put you in
jail well if that's a little messy for
you and you don't want to pay those
lawyer fees you can go into any grocery
store and get some nox gelatin women
know about noox gelatin because it's
good for your fingernails and your hair
and your skin it has the raw materials
for chicken cartilage has the raw
material for your cartilage
because made out of beef cartilage and
beef tendon and if you take two of those
little half ounce envelopes a day in
your orange juice and you take it with
an ounce per 100 pounds of body weight
of colloidal
minerals next time I come by here in 3
months you're going to run up on this
stage and hug me and kiss me if you got
arthritis how many you ever heard of
Alzheimer's disease everybody's heard
about it today 50 years ago when I was a
little kid there's no such thing as
Alzheimer's disease it's a new disease
one of those things that just sort of
happened now it's a major disease one
out of every two people who reach age 70
get Alzheimer's disease pretty scary
well we learned 50 years ago in the
animal industry how to prevent and cure
in the early stages Alzheimer's disease
and livestock you imagine how much a far
farmer would lose if the pigs were all
laying there scratching their head
saying
why am I
here where is the feed box because if if
they're not gaining a couple of pounds a
day you're losing money right so we
learned in the agricultural industry how
to prevent in the early stages cure
Alzheimer's disease and we do it with
high doses of vitamin E and low intakes
of vegetable oil you say wall like
that's crazy high doses of vitamin E
well you should have got a recall notice
from your doctor in July of 1992 because
the University of California I mean
we're talking about a sophisticated
research medical school here University
of California San Diego came out and
said vitamin E EAS is memory loss in
Alzheimer's victims now they're only 50
years behind on that from veterinary
medicine so it might be safer going to a
veterinarian then how many of you in
this room ever had a kidney stone
anybody in here ever get that kidney
stone okay I see a few in here what's
the first thing a doctor told you to
give up nutritionally when you got your
kidney stone give up calcium no Dairy no
Dairy none of those vitamin mineral
things with calcium in them because they
have the stupid naive ignorant belief
that's pretty intense they have the
stupid ignorant naive belief that the
calcium in your kidney stone comes from
the calcium you eat when in fact it
comes from your own bones when you have
a raging Calcium deficiency a raging
osteoporosis then you get kidney stones
we learned a thousand years ago in
writing in the agricultural industry if
you wanted to prevent kidney stones and
livestock you better give them more
calcium you better give them more
magnesium and more
Boron now the reason is of course bulls
and rams male cattle and sheep have
special in me when they get a kidney
stone they die they call water belly
they die when you and I get a kidney
stone we just wish we were dead but no
Farmers dumb enough to pay for the feed
for an animal and have it die before you
can either eat it or send it to Market
so we learned how to prevent those
things well you should have got a recall
notice from your doctor especially you
people who've had kidney stones your
urologist should have sent a notice to
you this was uh about 15 months ago
March of 1993 it says uh calcium limits
kidney stone risk and this is from the
havid Medical School up in Baston by the
way in a study that turns conventional
medical wisdom on its head researchers
have found that people whose diets are
rich in calcium run a reduce risk of
developing kidney stones in a study of
more than 45,000 people that who were
ranked into five categories the group
that had the most calcium had no kidney
stones so it took him a thousand years
to catch
up now about 5 years ago when I started
out on this Crusade and started
lecturing to people all across America
and I'm in one time zone the next and uh
all over I knew I was going to get crazy
out there uh doing this last year I was
on the road 300 days out of the Year 300
out of 365 days and so I decided I
needed to have a hobby that I could take
with me every time I get a little wacko
I could go in my room and do this Hobby
and I'd be okay you know be kind of like
having a little piece of home with me
wherever I went and I wanted to have a
hobby that would uh uh help other people
I didn't want to collect baseball cards
cuz I like football and I didn't want to
do just crossword puzzles cuz good
mental exercise but wouldn't help
anybody else and um I couldn't take my
compost pile I like the garden and the
hotels don't like that you know so I
decided I was going to collect
obituaries of doctors and
lawyers now as crazy as that sounds
remember I told you the doctors live to
an average age of 58 we live to 75.5 and
here's a group of people professionals
who pontificate you and tell you well
this is what you need to do you need to
give up salt and uh no caffeine and you
need to not eat butter and eat margarine
and do all these crazy things and they
die at age 58 on the average and of
course all those people who live to be
120 to 140 they put a chunk of rock salt
in their tea every day and they drink 40
Cups of Tea a day 40 chunks of rock salt
and they cook with butter instead of
olive oil and they live to be 120 so who
are you going to believe the people who
live to be 58 or the people who live to
be 120 it's your choice anyway got a few
of them here some of my favorites this
dror steuart cartright aged 38 he
dropped dead in his home he was a family
practitioner of a ruptured aneurism
that's a ballooning of an artery that's
a weakened artery because of the
fragmenting or the brittle condition of
the elastic fibers in arteries just like
when you hit a Chuck hole with your car
tire and you break the cords in there
and you get a
balloon he dropped dead like he was
poleaxed okay right in his home from a
ruptured a Arctic aneurysm now we
learned in 19 oh I think it was uh
57 aneurysms are caused by a copper
deficiency we had a pilot project
250,000 turkeys and we made complete
food pellets where you put all the 90
nutrients in there and in the first 13
weeks fully half of those turkeys died
125,000 of them farmers were out there
every morning picking them up by the
bushel basket they took them to the
state diagnostic labs and they're all
Topsy and they found out that they all
had died from a ruptured a Artic
aneurysm so they doubled the amount of
copper in there and the next year they
tried to raise 500,000 turkeys and they
didn't lose a single turkey from a
ruptured AR Artic aneurysm and they ran
that experiment in mice and rats and
rabbits and dogs and cats and uh calves
and sheep and pigs and whatnot and guess
what they found out that there's a whole
series of diseases that are caused by a
copper deficiency gray hair is the first
sign when you start getting gray hair
regardless of your age you got a copper
deficiency you got skin wrinkles because
the elastic fibers in your skin are
going those little crows feet around
your eyes and facial and body wrinkles
you look like you're a little prune
drying up
okay then of course there's the um uh
varicose veins varicose veins that's
caused by an elastic fiber breakdown
then of course parts of your body begin
to Sag under your arms your
breast your bellies your legs all this
stuff starts sagging and you can go to a
cosmetic surgeon or plastic surgeon if
you want but it's a lot cheaper and a
lot more effective and a lot safer if
you just take some
copper okay well Dr cartrite may have
had a
medical degree but he didn't have
expensive urine so he die to something
that even a turkey Wouldn't Die from
then here's one this fellow he he was a
doctor's doctor Dr Martin Carter he
almost made it he died at age
57 um he got his medical degree from
havid medical school and his PhD in
medicine from Yale of course um he was
autopsied by the best cuz he was a
doctor's Doctor Who said quote the cause
of death was a ruptured a Arctic
aneurism said Dr Jules H the Rockefeller
University Hospital unquote what did he
die from copper deficiency see he didn't
have expensive year in
either then here's an attorney she was
so famous she was from Detroit age 44
Ellen Joyce alter uh she was in the New
York Times obituary she made the big
time and uh of course she probably had
steel buns because she belonged to one
of those private health clubs all these
gals want steel buns you know doing
their little
exercises but she didn't have expensive
urine because she died of a ruptured
cerebral
aneurysm when they don't do an autopsy
the symptoms could be called a stroke or
uh subdural Hemorrhage but very
frequently they're caused by a ruptured
aneurysm which is a copper deficiency
she didn't have expensive urine how many
of you here have ever heard of a guy by
the name of steuart Burger Stuart Burger
he he wrote five best-selling books on
health and diets and nutrition uh he got
his medical degree from tus medical
school which is a very fine medical
school in Boston not too far away from
uh Harvard Medical School and the books
he wrote included the Southampton diet
for weight loss he wrote Forever Young
20 years younger and 20 weeks and how to
be your own nutritionist and he died at
age
40 how'd you like to follow his dietary
practices he died at age 40 of
cardiomyopathy which is a selenium
deficiency the same cause as white
muscle disease or or stiff lamb disease
and any farmer can go to a feed store
and get selenium pellets or selenium
injections things like celotto and
Boosey and so forth and Dr Stuart burer
a guy who wrote five bestselling books
on nutrition died of a nutritional
deficiency he didn't have expensive
urine now you can prevent totally
prevent cardiomyopathy for 10 cents a
day and if we don't do it we're
malignant dumb I like to call it you're
malignant dumb if you don't take in 10
cents a day worth of selenium it's a
waste of your life that's one of those
landmines you can avoid the medical
treatment of choice for cardiomyopathy
is a heart transplant cost
$750,000 I want you to think about that
they get the heart free from a
donor they get the blood free for the
surgery from the relatives
they use $2.50 worth of suture
material and they charge a
$750,000 for that procedure now 6 months
ago in La when they had the earthquake
they were putting people in jail for 60
and 90 days for price gouging for
selling these terrified people a gallon
of water for
$4 they put him in jail for price
gouging for selling him a gallon of
water for four bucks now to me that's
entrepreneurialism you know that's being
in business for yourself if you had a a
way to Ste water and make water and you
had a car and you could get in there and
sell those people a gallon of water for
four bucks hey more power to you because
if you go to a 7-Eleven and buy a quart
of e on water it's
$129 so four of those quarts is a five
bucks kind of interesting isn't it they
said it was price gouging because those
people were terrified well talk about a
person who needs a new heart they're
terrified
$750,000 we should put those doctors in
jail but we bow to them because oh
that's high tech medicine out of 270
million people in America you save about
50 a year is that cost effective I don't
think so I don't think so any rate Dr
Stuart burer didn't have expensive urine
and here's the last one and many of you
may know this woman uh her name is Dr
Gail Clark she was age 47 she was the
chief cardiologist of the West St Louis
County group of hospitals uh she was a
chief cardiologist for the um St Mary's
Health Center in Richmond Heights in St
Louis County she was age 47 guess what
she died from heart attack a cardiopathy
heart attack you can just see her
walking down the hall she's got the
stethoscope around her neck you know
this is their little status symbol got
my stethoscope around my neck back when
I was in school they folded it up very
bravely and put it in their
pocket boom she falls down she has a
heart attack right in the hall and of
course the nurses scoop her up and put
her on a gurnie and they call the
technicians and another doctor code
three code three code blue whatever it
is and they whiper into the room and you
can hear them let's say you're a cardiac
patient you're laying there you're all
hooked up to the monitors and the IVs
and and you hear them say okay te close
off okay stand back didn't work turn it
up stand back and then you hear that
terrible sound when you know that the
treatment didn't
work the Flatline when you know the
heart is gone and everybody walks out of
the room dejected and you say nurse
nurse what happened next door and she
says well you're cardiologist you know
the chief cardiologist of this Hospital
age 47 Dr Gail Clark just died of a
cardiomyopathy heart attack you can see
all the patients they're holding their
gowns and they're running out of that
hospital leaving their watches and their
shoes and their checkbooks and
everything and their plastic credit
cards because they don't want to get
what Dr Gail Clark
got to me the reader digest is a
magazine that never says anything
negative or bad about anybody or any
group it's the sweetest little magazine
that ever was the September 1993 issue
features an article it says can you
trust your
doctor it lists 12 ways the doctors scam
your money and I'll let you read 11 of
them yourself I'll give you the worst
one in addition to their income from
Office fees and surgical fees and lab
fees and hospitalization in addition to
all those fees doctors get a kickback
from the labs and the the X-ray labs and
Clinics and hospitals they get a
kickback of
$421 every time they send you in for a
CAT scan or an
MRI and doctors tell you oh we do that
because we're practicing defensive
medicine because if I miss something you
know one in 10 billion you're going to
sue me so I do this just to protect
myself well if it was just to protect
themselves and you knew them and they
knew you 90% of the people say I'll just
skip it DOC if you don't really think
it's necessary let's save the
money but they got something more than
defensive medicine to worry about they
get 421 bucks in a kickback for every
time they send you n for an MRI or a CAT
scan well when I practiced for 12 years
up in Portland somebody come to me with
a terrible headache never had one I just
walk up to them and tap them on the
sinuses and if they collaps to their
knees I know they had a sinus headache
oh doc why'd you do that well I just
wanted that's a cheap lab test you
know then if they had thank
you if they had blood dripping out of
their
nose if they had blood dripping out of
their nose it take a $35 x-ray to see if
they had a cancer in
there 35 bucks in a free lab test as
opposed to 421 bucks if I wanted to make
that 421 bucks I'd have been a good
Thief what I'd have done I'd have build
a choot right into that cat scan machine
cuz I knew how to build shoots living on
a farm and I'd have gone out in the
street and I'd have got every homeless
person I'd line them up in them shoots
and I'd put soup in a Big Mac at the end
of that tube you know and I say I'm
going to get buy you a $150 dinner I'm a
good guy I'm going to buy you a$1 50
dinner you just got to go through the
shoot go through that tube and you get
your sandwich and your soup man they'd
be flowing through there maybe hundred a
day and I could start adding some things
up it'd be a lot of fun any rate the
average doctor gets
$228,600 put in jail but doctors it's
okay because insurance pays for it
Hillary will pay for it we don't mind if
they steal it's blind it's free well I
remember I told you I was going to tell
you about
Pica Pica is a funny disease Pica I'm
not talking about the type style that
you see in typew Riders and computers
but p is a disease that farmers know
about uh in horses it's called cribbing
when they chew on the feed bunk the
wooden feed bunk you know you better
give them some minerals otherwise
they're going to eat eat that feed bunk
also uh in cattle dairy cattle
especially where they're losing lots of
minerals through their milk all the time
intensive milking you'll see them
picking up big rocks in the creek and
chewing on them or they'll chew on Bob
wire or maybe you'll see them walking
down through a path with a deer bone in
their mouth or something or a shingle
that's called Pica and a good farmer a
husbandman knows you better give them
some minerals otherwise they're going to
eat the barn or
something in human beings we see this at
funny times pregnant women are notorious
for pica uh the middle of the night
they'll elbow their husband and say Hey
you better get up I want some uh pickles
and ice cream they're craving minerals
because that fetus is pulling minerals
out of their body they need some more
minerals and so it's it's recognized as
a craving for things like sweets and
salt and so forth we see this in
pregnant women I used to have people
come to my practice and they say doct do
I need to go see a shrink I said why is
that well I wake up in the middle of the
night and I I go outside with a spoon
and I eat dirt and no that's okay just
make sure it's clean dirt
then they say my my kid sits there with
a kitty litter box between his legs and
has a spoon and he's eating that stuff
out of the kitty litter box and then in
housing projects little kids will eat
lead paint off the walls and they get
lead poison get learning disabilities
and Bone problems and anemia and we're
good so we spend $5 million to scrape
the lead paint off of there and repaint
it with latex paint and all we have to
do is give those kids 10 cents a day
worth of minerals it be better for them
and save us five million bucks it's your
tax money
and if we allow them to throw them away
those dollars is kind of interesting any
rate if you have a selenium deficiency
and you don't want to wait until you get
cardiomyopathy and drop dead from a
heart attack to recognize it if you look
on your hands and look in the mirror in
your face if you have liver spots or age
spots and I see quite a few from
here you have an early selenium
deficiency that's called free radical
damage and fortunately for you if you
recognize that and you start taking in
some colloidal selenium in four to 6
months those will all go away you'll
reverse that in four to 6 months and
when they go away on the outside they're
going away on the inside and your brain
and your heart and your liver and your
kidneys then if you have low blood sugar
how many in this room have low blood
sugar anybody in here have low blood
sugar okay about 10% how many you ever
seen a hyperactive kid who gets on
sugar okay about everybody in the room
people who have sugar problems are like
alcoholics there's good ones and bad
ones you know the good alcoholics are
one when they get two drinks they just
go off in a corner and go to sleep right
same way with somebody with low blood
sugar they eat a big meal or they eat a
piece of pie 3 hours later they clunk
out and go to sleep then there's bad
alcoholics they're the one that gets two
drinks in them and they get violent and
raged and they want to fight everybody
they punch holes in the wall and you
know big Brave fellows and they kick
their wife and kick the dog and take the
chainsaw and cut their neighbor tree
down and all these wild things and drive
Reckless down the roads and kill people
those are the bad drunks well people who
have blood sugar problems are bad blood
sugar people too they a little crazy
okay I don't know how many of you
remember the twinkie
defense right remember somebody murdered
two people and he claimed he ate a
Twinkie three hours before he murdered
him so they let him off because he got
temporarily insane every time he ate
sugar now don't any of you try
that well chromium and vadium deficiency
will result in the sugar problems low
blood sugar and if you let it go on for
any length of time you develop diabetes
chromium and vadium then deficiency the
early symptoms of a tin deficiency are
male pattern baldness I see a lot of tin
deficiency in this room yes and if you
let it go on for any length of time you
get
deafness then there's a boron deficiency
and you gal should know about boron
because it helps you keep the calcium
you take in in your bones so you don't
get
osteoporosis
Boron also it helps you make estrogen it
helps you fellas make testosterone if
you don't take in enough Boron you
ladies are going to suffer miserably
going through menopause okay you're
going to have all those terrible
symptoms you fellas don't get enough
Boron can't make testosterone you won't
know whether to lead or follow on the
Dance
Floor you're going to be
confused she's saying he's got a boron
deficiency then in laboratory oh I
should tell you too we said this on the
show today those of you may not have
heard it some of you didn't hear the
whole show the first symptoms of a zinc
deficiency is you lose your sense of
smell and your taste you say oh you know
food just doesn't taste good anymore and
you don't have a cold or anything like
that and you say your wife says well
aren't you excited about dinner I spent
the whole day in the kitchen cooking
dinner he said well I didn't smell
anything when I walked in you know he's
got a zinc deficiency well in laboratory
animals there's some seven rare Earths
these rare Earths are trace minerals you
need in lesser amounts than you need
trace minerals and they actually d
double the lifespan of laboratory
animals they've not been proven in
humans yet but I'm not going to wait 500
years for doctors to approve it there's
still arguing over vitamin C and calcium
right so I'm just going to do it didn't
kill any laboratory animals just doubles
her life and it's not a drug these rare
Earths are called lanthum prium neodium
samarium europium ubium and thulium
there must be a reason why they're named
after Old Testament cities well remember
I told you we needed 90 nutrients we
need 60 minerals we need 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids and three
essential fatty acids and of course
we're lucky in that plants as a group
can make most vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids plants can do that because
they just take carbon out of the air and
make carbon chains to make vitamins
amino acids and fatty acids but you have
to eat 15 to 25 different plants a day
in the right combinations to make this
happen theoretically it's possible but
most Americans don't do it the average
American thinks if they eat some potato
buds out of a Betty Croc box are eating
a vegetable okay so you got to be
careful what you're considering a
vegetable then of course people want to
do right by their Docker and they eat
lowfat turkey breast and they put a half
a jar of mayonnaise on there and they
put it between two slices of Wonder
styrofoam bread remember that stuff you
can insulate your house with and put in
your shoes when you get a hole in shoe I
remember when I was a kid 50 years ago
it was a lot of fun because we have
Wonderbread we didn't have TVs back then
on the farm we didn't even have dryers
that went round and round so the only
thing you could do in the winter time
was sit in the kitchen and wand at a
loaf of Wonderbread and it had the blue
and red and green yellow balloons on
there and if you read the label as many
times as I do you know it said things
like helps build bodies at 12 ways and
about 15 years later the FDA made him
change it to help build your body eight
ways now if you go to the store and look
at Wonderbread rappers it just says
Wonderbread so it kind of gives you a
clue so even though this is
theoretically possible it's not likely
to happen that that you're going to get
your vitamins amino acids and fatty
acids in proper proportions from your
diet and so if your life is as valuable
to you as mine is to me and my
children's and my grandchildren's is to
me I would make sure that I take in all
my vitamins and amino acids and fatty
acids because I guarantee you you won't
make it to 120 or 140 if you don't
you're just not going to do it now
minerals are another story we have a
tragic story when it comes to minerals
because plants cannot make minerals in
any way shape or form and if they're not
in the soil anymore they're not in our
plants we have for you when you leave a
free copy of a summary of US Senate
document 264 US Senate document 264 is
from the 74th Congress second session
and it says that our farm soils and our
rain soils are depleted of minerals and
the crops the grains the fruits and the
vegetables and the nuts that are grown
on these depleted farm and Rain soils
are minerally deficient and the people
who eat them get mineral deficiency
diseases and the only way to prevent and
cure them is with mineral supplements as
US Senate document 264 74th Congress
second session it was written and
printed by the US Congress in
1936 58 years ago you think it's gotten
any better no it has not gotten any
better it's only gotten worse and the
reason is if you guys do what we did and
people continue to do is we put NPK on
our land nitrogen phosphorus potassium
and you see it as these three numbers in
many combinations of of um ratios and
these represent percentages of these
three nutrients nitrogen phosphorus
potassium and those of you who don't
have any experience on farms the reason
why we do this is farmers get paid for
tons and bushels there's no subsidy that
encourages people to put 60 minerals
back in the soil you get paid for tons
and bushels and for 40 bucks an acre you
can get the maximum yield in tons and
bushels it only takes 5 to 10 years to
deplete the land of minerals CU every
time you harvest a crop those plants
pull minerals out of the soil many
pounds per acre every time you haul a
crop out so soon those minerals are gone
and if you only put back in three and
you take out 60 it's like a checking
account if you only put three bucks in
your checking account every month and
write checks for 60 what's going to
happen to your checks boing boing boing
they bounce exactly well I can tell you
that our health is bouncing right now to
the tune of $1.2 trillion dollar a year
because there's no more minerals left in
our
it's our responsibility each and every
one of us to be responsible for our
health and consciously take in these
minerals I have a lot of people ask me
what did these people do thousands of
years ago they didn't even have
commercial fertilizers what did they do
these societies that had longli people
and whatnot I want you to think about
the Egyptians the Chinese uh people from
India that lived around these Great
Rivers the Nile River the Ganges River
um the yo river in China and what used
to happen was every year our so it would
flood just like it did here in Northern
Missouri last year and every time it
flooded guess what would happen it would
bring silt or rock dust from Mountains
from 500 or thousand miles away and
those people would pray to every God
they had the water God the sky God the
wind God The Rock God to flood we pray
don't flood they used to pray to flood
because they had their floods during the
winter time and would put silt and
minerals back in the soil and their
grain was very valuable King Philip
who's the father of uh Alexander the
Great married the 12-year-old child
queen of Egypt Cleopatra she didn't look
like Elizabeth Taylor all made up in
beautiful costumes she was a little
flatchested teeny bopper not very sexy
but Philip married her because she
controlled the best wheat in the world
and if he wanted his Macedonian army to
conquer the world through his son
Alexander the Great he needed the best
wheat in the world so he could March 20
hours a day fight for 6 hours and win if
they use the wheat from the depleted
soils and greas they couldn't go 20
minutes without saying mommy pick me up
can you imagine these big Greek soldiers
Oh my legs hurt pick me up and so they
knew the best place to get wheat was
from
Egypt it was those floods that gave them
those minerals and all those cultures
that came up with all the great art and
all the great technology came from those
PE places because they had more
intelligence because they had more
nutrition more minerals I heard somebody
say very good we getting the picture
well what I'm going to do here is I'm
just going to pick out a a couple of
minerals just a couple of them so you
get the idea it applies to all of them
let's just pick out a common one like
calcium everybody knows about calcium
Calcium deficiency will result in
something like 147 different diseases
they're just different names they're
named after people like Bell's paly
Bell's paly is you know everybody knows
about that one side of your face sags
it's not a true stroke it just affects
your facial muscles it's caused by
Calcium deficiency we'll talk about in a
little bit but everybody knows about
this one osteoporosis it's the number 10
killer of adults United States it's very
expensive it cost you $35,000 each for
each hip to replace it's okay it's
free insurance or Medicare or Hillary
will pay for it cost you $70,000 for
both hips as expensive as it is and the
number 10 killer remember Mrs SKS from
Radford Virginia aged 115 years of age
she died of complications of a fall
we don't have osteoporosis and animals
and it's because of farmers we don't
have osteoporosis and animals goes like
this you have a a pasture with 100 cows
in it and this year you didn't have any
calves you can't repay your operating
loan you're in trouble right because you
paid for the feed and the vet bill and
mow the pasture and fertilize and
maintain the fence and fed the cows and
all this that and the other you don't
have any cash you can't pay back the
oper operating load and make any money
so you call the vet out and you say do I
get rid of these cows what happened here
and he exam the cow he says nothing
wrong with them he says let me look at
the bull and he say aha here's your
problem that bull has osteoporosis of
both hips can't breed the cows didn't
have any calves he says I'll tell you
what though he says you give me $70,000
he says I'll put two new hips in that
bull and next year you'll have some
calves well the first thing that farmer
says is stand back doc
boom he blows that bull away with a deer
rifle and well the kids are grinding the
kid uh the uh well the kids are grinding
the bull up with um a grinder and
cutting roast and steaks off that bull
the farmer is chewing on a straw and
saying now Doc pushes Stetson up a
little bit and he says you know he says
uh you know I wasn't going to pay you
$70,000 for that old bull he says I get
a new bull every year for 70 years for
that he says but every once in a while I
get a bull that throws good calves I'd
like to keep them is there any way I can
prevent that osteoporosis thing for
happening to a good bull he says well
yeah he says if you'll give a bull CF 10
cents worth of calcium every day after
he's weaned he'll never get osteoprosis
fir now wait a minute doc you mean if I
give that bull 10 cents a day worth of
calcium from the time he's weaned I can
prevent a
$70,000 disaster oh yeah it's that
simple he says you mean all I have to do
is give up a half a cup of coffee a day
to do that he says yeah that's it he
says I choose that one he say I'll give
up the half a cup of coffee and that's
what we have to think like okay then
there's receding
gums dentist and periodontist will tell
you that if you want to prevent and cure
receding gums you better floss and brush
after every meal if you believe that
works I have some oceanfront property in
Montana to sell you if you all know your
geography you know that doesn't work now
as a veterinarian I've seen hundreds of
thousands of animals of all kinds mice
rats rabbits dogs cats sheep pigs horses
lions and tigers and bears and they
don't get receding gums and they don't
floss now they do get funky breath but
they don't get seed and gums boy if you
want to smell something you just let a
camel breathe on you
boy well the reason we don't have
receding gums and livestock is because
we've dealt with the osteoporosis
problem receding gums is not a
deficiency of flossing it's in fact
osteoporosis of the jaw bones and of the
facial bones so if you have gingivitis
or receding gums you have advanced
osteoporosis those bones around your
teeth are melting away little bit by a
little bit every day and if you take
your teeth out at night and put them in
a glass next to your bed and that fizzy
stuff you have major advanced
osteoporosis because all your bone has
melted away okay then there's
arthritis we talked about that a little
bit earlier remember the chicken
cartilage or the nox gelatin 85% of all
arthritis is caused by osteoporosis of
the joint ends of the bones you're
talking about degenerative arthritis
osteoarthritis sciatica lumbago rheuma
ISM all those sorts of things um they're
caused by osteoporosis of the joint ends
of the bones I want you to think about
something for a minute if you don't take
a pain reliever or or an
anti-inflammatory for that arthritis
let's say you get arthritis of the hips
you're going to kind of favor that a
little bit aren't you you're going to
get a cane or a walker or crutches
you're going to favor it and so you
don't put any weight on it I want you to
think about that for just a second
because then I want you to think about
driving your tractor in a field or
you're driving a Mercedes down the
highway either one doesn't matter
whichever you love
more and um let's say you didn't put the
nut on that oil pan real tight and all
the oil drained out and that light on
the dashboard comes on says I'm getting
hot you better give me some oil and that
light irritates you so you stop you open
up the hood you get your clippers out
you know your fence Clippers and you
clip the the wire to that light and you
close the hood and you just keep driving
would you do that to your tractor or
your Mercedes no you wouldn't but we
take those pain relievers for arthritis
we go out there and square dance and do
the Texas step and do our F mile walks
and our aerobics that pill Works real
good doc cuz it killed my pain and
you're just wearing that thing off
faster and
faster then your doctor is really going
to get rich because you need joint
replacement
surgery then there's hypertension this
is one of my favorites I'll put a star
over
here hypertension is high blood pressure
what's the first nutritional thing that
a doctor will tell you to give up
nutritional when you get high blood
pressure give up salt everybody knows
that one that's been ingrained in our
head well they must think we're dumber
than cows because what's the first thing
you put out for your livestock and it's
about that big a salt block no farmer is
going to be economically viable if you
don't put a salt block out for your
livestock they're going to die your
Veterinary bills are going to go crazy
but we're supposed to believe that we
don't need salt you can get everything
you need out of your lettuce and your
whole wheat bread and stuff like that
well don't believe that one either if
you believe believe that I got some more
oceanfront property in Montana for you
remember those long live people put a
big chunk of rock salt the size of a big
black concord grape and every cup of tea
and they drink about 40 Cups of Tea a
day because they live at high altitudes
where it's very dry they have to keep
hydrated and they put butter in their
tea they put two Pats of butter and a
chunk of rock salt they don't put the
pink stuff or the blue stuff or skin
milk or what does they call it uh creora
or whatever it is
okay guess guess what the doctors who
live to be 58 tell you no salt no butter
the people who live to be 1220 they put
in butter and salt so you got to make
some choices well they took $30 million
of your tax money and two years ago
after a 20e study they came out and said
that they took 5,000 people with high
blood pressure they took them off their
medication and put them on a reduced
salt diet a restricted salt diet and
they all died no big surprise but
somebody got a PhD degree and everybody
was happy happy right but when they
looked at this results they said that oh
only
99.7% of the people didn't get any
results from that before they died 0.3%
did get some result dropped their blood
pressure one point before they died by
restricting their salt so the referees
who judged that article said oh doesn't
matter you might as well let high blood
pressure patients eat salted peanuts and
deal pickles and salt their food to
taste because it doesn't matter in fact
worrying about the salt is more stress
than taking the salt then they had a
control group with 5,000 people with
high blood pressure and they doubled
their RDA of calcium and they stopped
the experiment in 6 weeks because 85% of
them were cured of their high blood
pressure just by doubling their calcium
intake now they didn't cold turkey stop
their high blood pressure medication but
what they did was they went to the
doctor and says you don't need this
medication anymore what are you doing
well I'm on this experiment where I
double my calcium intake anybody get a
recall notice from your doctor saying
it's okay to Salt your food to taste and
please do double your calcium intake
anybody get that not a single one that's
very interesting then of course there's
H insomnia that's where you roll around
all night and you get your you wake up
in the morning you're more tired when
you went to bed that's insomnia of
course doctors have two treatments for
that they have hion which is a sleeping
pill and they have barbituates they kill
about 10,000 people a year with
overdoses of those things but that's
okay it's a prescription and they're
watching out for us and remember
remember uh George Bush when he went to
Japan they gave him some helon so he
could sleep on the way to Japan because
of the time difference and when he woke
up one of the the side effects of helon
is nausey and
vomiting I don't know how you say it in
Japanese but it was very dramatic on
world TV right not very
presidential and so I'm sure that's why
he lost the election because he puked
over that Japanese
ambassador
and then of course there's kidney
stones and then there's bone spurs heel
spurs and calcium deposits again
Physicians will tell you the first thing
to give up nutritionally is calcium and
dairy because they have this foolish
belief the stupid belief the ignorant
belief that the calcium in kidney stones
bone spurs heel spurs and calcium
deposits come from uh your diet when
instead it only comes from your bones
when you have a aging osteoporosis and
when you get these things you need more
calcium not less then there's cramps and
Twitches you wake up in the middle of
the night and your foot is all cramped
up around your neck and you say Lord
take me from the knee down I'm not going
to make it till morning we've all
experienced that that's very
common then there's PMS premenstrual
syndrome you know the emotional and
physical stuff the medical treatment of
choice for PMS is what we call a
hysterical ectomy it's been been
shortened to hysterctomy that's a 100y
old treatment the doctors do about
285,000 unnecessary hysterical ectomies
a year but it makes Mercedes payments so
they do them even the AMA said they're
unnecessary but they don't take their
licenses away and people keep going to
them you imagine a poor woman in her 30s
she says doc you got to do something
every time I go out to hang out the
clothes my neighbors kids run down the
basement screaming which my own kids
think I'm crazy my husband's leaving me
I'm going to lose my job you got to do
something well the University of
California San go came out 3 years ago
now and said if you just double the RDA
of calcium intake you get rid of 85% of
the emotional and physical symptoms of
PMs and when that came out there were
huge lines around the health food stores
around the blocks and people had
sleeping bags CU they closed before they
all got their calcium and every person
in line was a
man they were there for their daughters
and their girlfriends and their wives
and things like
that okay and lastly is low low back
pain 85% of Americans get low back pain
whether you work on a computer or you
unload hay or you drive big trucks
doesn't matter low back is a big problem
low back is just osteoporosis of the
vertebrae whether you have a disc
problem or whatnot because if your disc
doesn't have anything to hold on to your
vertebrae have melted away what's going
to happen to the disc especially if you
have a copper deficiency because they're
made out of elastic fibers they go like
a water balloon with a lot of pressure
on them well I just want you to look at
this quickly before we do the last
mineral low back you go to an orthopedic
surgeon or rheumatologist you might get
a muscle relaxant you might get valium
and a muscle relaxant you get a
laminectomy you get your vertebrae fuse
you might get a dis operation they don't
tell you 75% of the time you'll never be
the same again right PMS you go to your
OBGYN you can um go to an internist you
can go to a family counselor a shrink or
a divorce attorney cramps and Twitches
you go to a neurologist you go to a
sports medicine doctor an internist bone
spurs heel spurs calcium deposits you go
to a rheumatologist an orthopedic
surgeon or a podiatrist kidney stones
you go to a urologist or an internist or
a surgeon insomnia you go to a shrink or
a um Sleep Clinic or an internist
hypertension you go to a Cardiologist an
internist or a surgeon arthritis
rumatologist a orthopedic surgeon or an
internist receding gums you go to a
dentist or periodontist osteoporosis you
go to all those Health Specialists
including a tum salesman for nothing
more than a Calcium deficiency it cost
you 10 cents a day to deal with now on
the average because Americans have
insurance and we have Medicare and
Medicaid we spend on the average $25,000
to
$250,000 and we undergo 5 to 10 surgical
procedures a year for a Calcium
deficiency and we beg the doctors to do
it we beg the doctors to do it well it's
our choice the last one I'll share with
you is diabetes everybody's touched by
diabetes it's the number three cause of
death in adults in the United States
number three cause of death and it has
terrible complications and side effects
diabetes the side effects include
blindness of many
kinds then there's a kidney failure with
dialysis and kidney transplant there's
cardiovascular disease of all kinds and
of course that contributes the number
one cause of death which is the number
one cause of death uh then there is
amputations everybody ought to have one
of those because they're totally paid
for in their health thing they assume
that you're not just going to get one
because you want to get everything on
your health benefits and then you
shorten your life because if you have
diabetes on the average you have a
shorter lifespan than someone who
doesn't have diabetes now we learned in
1957 in the animal industry that we
could prevent and cure diabetes with two
trace minerals that's pretty profound
statement that we could prevent and cure
diabetes with two trace minerals in 1957
and animals it was published in
Federation proceedings which is the
official Journal of the American Science
the National Institutes of Health the
official monthly Journal was August
1957 well the two trace minerals that
you can get to prevent and cure this are
chromium and vadium vadium alone
according to the University of Vancouver
British Columbia Medical School vadium
alone will replace
insulin in adult onset diabetics which
represent 85% of all diabetics of course
they can't quit their insulin cold
turkey they got to gradually wean off of
it takes four to 6 months for most
people to slowly wean off of insulin if
they're taking in adequate amounts of
chromium and vadium I've seen it work on
hundreds and hundreds of people now to
me this is Criminal because if you write
to a Hills packing company that makes
ss. dog food right over here in Topeka
Kansas I don't know if I'm pointing West
but that way okay they're all saying
that
way TOA Kansas they manufacture sence
diet dog food and other sence diet
product high-tech foods for Animals if
you write them and say how many minerals
exactly is in Science Diet for dog food
they'll write you back and say there's
40 minerals you write checkerboard
Square in St Louis R sh and say just how
many minerals are in your rat pellets
for laboratory rats and they'll say
there's 28
minerals I'll give anybody in this room
a crisp new $100 bill if you can find me
a human infant formula in a grocery
store that has more than 11 so our dogs
get FY minerals remember that's what
Mike Murphy was saying his dog never
seems to get sick CU he's getting this
canned dog food with all these vitamins
and minerals in there so our dogs get
farty minerals our rats get 28 minerals
and our human infants get
11 is that fair no that's called
fraud doesn't matter if you're talking
about SMA Similac Isomil Pro soy B fact
that's why they call call Similac
Similac cuz it lacks
everything okay if I've convinced you
that you have to consciously take in all
the minerals yourself that you can't
depend on your food and certainly you
can't depend on anything that's boxed or
packaged or bottled there's three types
of minerals that you have to be
concerned about one is metallic minerals
and metallic minerals are essentially
groundup rocks metallic minerals are
things like oyster shell eggshell
Dolomite Limestone uh calcium carbonate
Clays of various kinds Mount marinite
clay seabed minerals they're
Tums they're only 8 to 12% absorbable
When You Reach age 35 to 40 it drops
down to 3 to
5% and I have to tell you a story here
some of you heard this on the show today
I ran into a guy at a meeting like this
up at Grand Rapids Michigan and this
fell owns a portapotty business you know
that's that green or blue colored ous
man if we' only had one of those back
when I was a kid we had these ones with
splinters you know in the in the wood
any rate um he said I see some one
something that that describes that in my
portapotty business I said what's that
he says well when we take those things
back to the shop to clean them out with
a pressure hose he says we put a quarter
inch grid underneath them because kids
throw rocks and sticks and toys in there
and if we don't put a grid there it
blocks up the sewer system it cost us
thousands of dollars to fix it he says
every time we clean one of those out we
find hundreds of vitamin tablets I said
well how do you know they're vitamin
tablets he says well that's really easy
he says right on the coating it says
there gr M One A Day
Centrum he says come here he takes me
out in the back of his shop and there's
this literal mountain of all these
vitamin pills he got out of his porta
potties that's because you can't absorb
metallic minerals if you read the labels
on those multiples they say your iron
comes in the form of iron oxide what is
iron oxide
rust you might as well just go out to an
old railroad track and take your butter
knife and scrape some of that rust off
and lick it and you're going to get your
iron supplement well that's what they're
giving you well I'll show you how bad it
is if you take something like calcium
lactate was which is a common metallic
mineral uh let's say it's a calcium tab
calcium lactate 1,000
milligrams if you take two of those
you're not getting 2,000 milligrams of
calcium in fact I have people all the
time say well I took lot of calcium doc
I hear you on the radio talking about
calcium and arthritis and I took 2,000
milligrams of calcium a day didn't help
my arthritis in fact it got worse and so
what kind of calcium you taken they said
calcium lactate well there's your
problem because only 250 milligrams of
that is metallic calcium so let's say
you absorb 10% of that then the other
750 milligrams is lactose or milk
sugar so 10% of
250 is 25 so if you take two of those
tablets you're not getting two ,000
you're getting 50
milligrams so to get what you need you
need to take 90 of those tablets a day
you need to take 30 with each meal and
you got 59 more minerals to
go then there's those people who want to
do things naturally let's see if you can
do anything good with 10 pounds of
spinach and let's be fair let's see if
you can get 1,000 milligrams of
magnesium I picked magnesium because in
green leafy vegetables you have a lot of
magnesium because of the chlorophyll
right it's part of the chlorophyll
molecule and any pound of anything you
got 450 4 G and 10 lb of spinach you got
4540 G of which most of that 97% is
water let's say you have 1 gram of
chlorophyll in that 10 lbs of spinach
there's 50 milligrams of magnesium you
got to divide that into the Thousand you
want you get a factor of 20 which you
multiply times the 10 you have to eat
200 lb of spinach you got 58 more
minerals to
go okay so you got to be a pretty big
person to accomplish all this even as
big as I am you can't get it done so I
prefer to supplement rather than do
those things then of course during the
60s the agricultural industry came up
with Keel minerals Keel lated minerals
because Farmers aren't dumb enough to
pay for a dollar of something that goes
into an animal's mouth and have 99 Cents
come out in the manure so I have to
really thank Farmers for being that
clever and chelated minerals are just
metallic minerals with an amino acid or
protein or enzyme wrapped around the
metal atom and increase the
absorbability to 40% then the hell food
industry jumped on that right away
because it was a major Improvement in
absorbability of minerals the most
efficient way to absorb minerals is the
colloidal Farm colloidal minerals are
98% absorbable two and a half times more
available than chelated minerals and 10
times more available than metallic
minerals and they're very interesting
they're liquid they can only be liquid
can't be pills powders or uh capsules
they're very small particle size are
7,000 times smaller than a red blood
cell and they're negatively charged
every particle is negatively charged
your intestinal lining is positively
charged so you actually have an
electrical or magnetic gradient that
concentrates these minerals around the
lining of your intestin these three
things together give you the 98%
absorbability now plants have a very
interesting part to play in colloidal
minerals remember we said that plants
cannot create minerals if they're not in
the soil plants can't make them
remember that US Senate document 264
says they're not in the soil anymore at
any rate metallic minerals are taken up
by plants when they're in the soil
plants convert them in their tissues to
colloidal minerals and this is how we
store minerals in our body this is how
we use minerals in our body this is how
we transport minerals from their storage
place to their site of use in the
colloidal Farm well our plants our crops
don't have much in the way of colloidal
minerals in them because we don't have
any metallic minerals in our soil is
this important well yeah these long live
cultures who live to be 120 to 140 they
have certain common denominators they
all live in high mountain Villages that
are above 8500 to 14,000 ft in elevation
they all have less than 2 inches of
precipitation a year they don't have any
rain they don't have any snow they don't
have any de okay very very dry places
and guess what they get all their
drinking water and all their irrigation
water for their crops from what we call
glacial milk glaciers in every one of
those communities grind up the parent
Rock of those mountains about 4 in a
year there's more than 60 to 72 minerals
in each one of those places the water
that comes out from underneath those
glaciers is not clear like perier or
Evon water or Poland water or geyser
water you take a glass full of it up and
then hold it up it looks like Jersey
milk I mean it is either yellow white or
white blue it looks like milk and it's
called in titty Kaka see I got to say it
again in titty Kaka or tobet they all
call it glacial milk cuz it looks like
milk and not only have they consumed it
drunk it and got 8 to 12% until they
were 35 to 40 then 3 to 5% absorption
for 2500 to 5,000 years depending on the
culture more importantly they have
irrigated with it year after year crop
after crop generation after generation
for 2 200 to 5,000 years they have no
diabetes they have no heart disease no
high blood pressure no arthritis no
osteoporosis no cancer no cataracts no
glaucoma they have no birth defects
they have no jails full of drug
addicts they have no taxes they have no
doctors yet they live to be 120 to 140
without disease are these collidal
minerals important You Bet Your Life
they're important and every time you
don't take them in every day you're
chopping off a few hours or a few days
of your life okay now most people are
not going to go to hanza or Tibet or
titty
Kaka because we don't have Kenmore
kitchens there or even Saturn cars or TV
Changers Channel Changers or electricity
they don't have insulated houses they
don't have central heating or air
conditioning but what they do have is
colloidal
minerals this is Dr wallik with a final
message information gives you the
ability to make decisions with
confidence I hope you've enjoyed my
message by giving your body the proper
raw materials every day you'll be taking
the necessary steps in living healthier
and living longer make the decision to
take control of your personal Health and
Longevity program today colloidal
minerals are not like antibiotics you
don't get a prescription which you use
for 10 days and then you're done your
prescription for colloidal minerals
should only expire when your need for
oxygen expires you need to supplement
your diet with the 90 essential
nutrients each and every day of your
life millions of people have heard my
message all across the world and have
now decided decided to make the
consumption of colloidal minerals a
daily ritual just as there are many
manufacturers of aspirin there are now
many manufactures of vitamins and
mineral supplements be sure to get your
liquid colloidal minerals derived only
from the very best organic plant Source
deposits colloidal minerals are the
mineral Source our bodies were designed
to use not groundup rocks since you will
most likely be supplementing your diet
each and every day don't get caught
paying retail prices my daddy always
said Why Pay retail when you can buy
wholesale one of my trusted colleagues
will show you how to purchase the
highest quality products wholesale so
you can save gobs money off the retail
price each
year